so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about psylocke also known as
Betsy Braddock and what I'm hoping is
that at the end of this video you'll
have a good understanding of her
character as well as why she's proven to
be such an important and popular
character in the x-men and Marvel Comics
so while she's better known for her role
as part of the x-men team Psylocke made
her first appearance at the twin sister
of Brian Braddock in Captain Britain
comics as part of Marvel UK decide track
here as it was originally founded in
1972 while UK was formed as a
publication and that reprinted American
comics for British readers and did not
actually begin producing original
material until 1976 when the company
released Captain Britain weekly written
by Chris Claremont and drawn by artist
herb shrimp while the comic was
originally released on a weekly basis in
an effort to boost sales and maintain
the cohesive universe Captain Britain
was crossed over in the model UK's
reprinted version of spider-man in 1977
leading to massive success attributed
largely to Marvel's most popular heroes
allowing for exposure to the Captain
Britain character because Claremont's
writing style focus on expanding the
characters while maintaining strong
storytelling and ninja number eight as
it was released in December of 1976
Betsy Braddock debuted as a twin sister
of Brian now something to take note of
was it at this point in time like most
everyone else Betsy did not know of her
brothers identity as Captain Britain but
her introduction came by way of the fact
that her older brother Jamie Braddock
had been involved in a car crash
under mysterious circumstances as she
explains to Brian
Jamie had been driving his Formula One
racecar along the track behind the
Braddock mansion when it suddenly spun
out of control due to unknown means as a
result Betsy was forced to watch as the
car collided with a line of trees and
exploded while Betsy was able to smother
the flames the situation got out of
control leading her to turn to Brian and
never to discover why the crash had
occurred and how to save Jamie's life to
this end Clem Watt began fleshing out
the early aspects of Silex character by
establishing that she was an
accomplished charter pilot and that she
was able to bring Brian back to their
mansion by plane as well as her latent
psychic powers by having the plane
psychically attacked by
dr. syne tormented by visions of
monsters put into her head by sign
Betsey crashed and Brian transformed
into Captain Britain doing battle with
sign himself while trying to avoid his
mind-control powers and so after a
skirmish where Captain Britain is able
to break free of science control on him
and wakes up his Brian Braddock at the
mansion with his brother Jamie who
appears to be absolutely fine psylocke
Slayton abilities come into play when
sine returns later that night taking
over the mind of Psylocke and forcing
her to elucidate the same monsters from
her time on the plane not realizing that
she's actually seeing her family now
where the story would see his conclusion
in the defeat of dr. sine as a character
Clement created with the intention of
being an ongoing part of the Captain
Britain title Silex revelation of ryan
braddock being captain britain served to
allow her to operate behind the scenes
as a kind of sidekick to his character
giving her mother attentional for future
development
however while captain britain was fairly
popular with audiences because his
editor had an entirely different idea of
what the story should be which
conflicted with Claremont's views of
both the character and the world of
marvel claremont vacated his position is
writer 10 issues n following this after
realising the success that came with
Marvel's first line wide crossover in
the form of contest of Champions as well
as smaller crossovers in various titles
the decision was made to eliminate the
Captain Britain series following his
character and supporting characters over
into the larger Marvel landscape where
Captain Britain himself experienced a
revolving door in the sense that he was
thrown into the anthology series Marvel
Super Heroes and Daredevils under the
control of Alan Moore and Alan Davis
with stories at the crooked world and
Madge in Jasper's in terms of Psylocke
her first major changes began to occur
in the form of abandoning her career as
a charter pilot becoming a model and
dyeing her hair purple furthermore
because clients time as writer was so
short the explanation of Psylocke
psychic abilities was left ambiguous
leaving future writers to flesh these
concepts out as a result within the
stories of Captain Britain while Brian
was away at college
Psylocke psychic talents were noticed by
the side division of strike Britain's
version of shield and existed as a
special tactical reserve for
international key emergencies focusing
on crimes and missions that went above
and beyond the capabilities of local law
enforcement and the mi
five working alongside some of one was
most powerful telepaths and employed for
the purpose of helping with emissions in
a way the strikes noble members couldn't
select recruitment came by way of a man
named agent Matthew who was in charge of
seeking out telepaths for the
organization taking place in the
Daredevils line of colleagues written by
Alan Moore and art from Allen Davis
during her time on the team psylocke
began a love affair with fellow psychic
and strike murderer Tom Lennox who
possessed both telepathic and
telekinetic abilities using this as a
means to expand her powers Morin Davis
depicted the conversations between Linux
and Psylocke taking place telepathically
allowing for fast tracking ever
capabilities without the need for a
full-on explanation of what she was able
to do now because these stories took
place within the pages of Daredevils for
the series being canceled and all the
characters and events transitioned in
the mighty world of Marvel alongside
more popular heroes Alan Moore and Allen
Davis's story of Mad Jim Jasper's was
literally stretched across three
different titles but continued to see a
rise in popularity for the Captain
Burton character as he faced off against
one of Marvel's most powerful villains
however because Betsey existed as a
supporting character whose popularity
was beginning to rival that of her
brother owing to her telepathic powers
and the idea that she herself was
capable of far more than what she seemed
as a creator of Betsy and the current
writer for New Mutants Chris Claremont
and the process of rolling her over into
the x-men universe beginning with New
Mutants annual number two in 1986 coming
out of a two-part story and Captain
Britain vol two issues 12 and 13 which
saw Betsy's eyes gouged out during a
battle with the villain slay master
after taking to Switzerland to
recuperate and forgoing the use of
Bionic eyes using her telepathic
abilities to allow herself to see her
recovery is short-lived when she's
kidnapped by mojo the ruler of the
extra-dimensional mojo purse which
serves to provide its inhabitants
entertainment by way of gladiator like
television programs brainwashing Betsy
and giving her cybernetic eyes as well
as a future codename Psylocke mojo uses
her along with other brainwashed mutants
for a television show called wild ways
where Betsy and the rest of the group
are saved by SCI lock and cypher two of
the new mutants Bessie's taken to the
x-men mansion to recover coinciding with
a launch of the mutant Massacre as
Marvel's first crossover between the
x-men related titles while the main
story itself
on Sinister's marauders killing the
Morlocks within the sewers of New York
while she wasn't technically a member of
the team psylocke was able to prove
herself capable by saving the other
mutants in the mansion's infirmary when
the Marauders led by Sabretooth
infiltrated the mansion distracting
Sabretooth and leaving him away from the
other ailing patients which included
Nightcrawler Colossus and Kitty Pryde
Betsy's battle with Sabretooth was
entirely one-sided until Wolverine and
stone appeared allowing psylocke the
opportunity to look into Sabretooth mind
learn his connection to mr. sinister and
grant Wolverine a momentary distraction
resulting in Sabretooth to feed as a
result Claremont used the conclusion of
the storyline as it means to officially
induct SiteLock into the team under the
auspices that her ability to
telepathically distract Sabretooth
served as a catalyst to not only allow
the x-men victory but showed them the
hidden hand behind the mutant Massacre
now going forward into the main uncanny
x-men series as was written by Claremont
Psylocke became an extremely valuable
member of the team aiding in battles
against villains like the brood
abomination the orphan maker and the
Savage Land mutates however at this
point in time while psylocke had
respectable psychic powers which
included telepathy mind control astral
projection and the ability to speak to
other people's minds across long
distances she had no real physical
fighting skills and in fact during a
battle against a villain called
adversary whose sole purpose in life is
to bring chaos and destruction to the
universe to the use of magic bed to
yourself was actually killed taking
place as part of the fall of mutants
storyline in uncanny x-men issues - 25
through 27 from January to March of 1988
well the story's conclusion saw the
world assuming the x-men had died
leaving deny crawler in Kitty Pryde
helping to form Britain's superhero team
Excalibur and truth the x-men had been
allowed passage to the siege perilous a
device that allows for those that pass
through it to begin their lives anew
without any knowledge of their past
experiences initiated by Claremont is a
soft reboot in an effort to wipe away
her convoluted history and create a
wholly new character with uncanny x-men
issue number 256 in 1989 the psylocke
woke up on an island in Asia where she
was found by the hand a group of ninjas
focusing on sorcery with ties to Hydra
during which time she was taken to their
leader Matsuo
who swapped her mind with his lover
Kuantan who was brain dead under the
believe it's eyeluxe telepathy would
save quantum leading into the revelation
that betsy had been split into two beams
both of whom had been mentally fused in
such a way that you both share the same
memories but each retain half of
psylocke psychic powers because she
maintained amnesia following her trip to
this huge perilous the new psylocke
became an assassin of the hand operating
under the mantle of lady mandarin at the
same time the body swap of Psylocke
allowed claremont to introduce a whole
new set of abilities including martial
arts and the ability to use her
celebrity to create psychic weapons most
notably her trademark psychic dagger
which was described as the focused
totality of her telepathic powers
however because a transition needed to
end the psylocke returning to the x-men
team or else being killed off due to
fandom and in a general sense of
continuity an uncanny x-men issues 270
through 272 Psylocke was hit in a battle
against warframe during which time her
telepathic dagger penetrated Logan's
body granting psylocke the revelation
that she was not an assassin after all
but an x-man after which she rejected
the role of lady Mandarin following this
and with Chris Claremont leading the
x-men series in 1991 due to
disagreements with artist Jim Lee and
editor Bob Harris the script writing
duties changed hands several times with
John Byrne taking over for issues 281
through 286 and Scott lowdown taking
over after that at the same time while
the launch of x-men vol 2 saw the team's
split into two groups with Gold team
functioning an uncanny x-men and the
blue team serving as part of expand all
you to Psylocke became part of the blue
team where she attempted a former
romantic relationship with Cyclops
something that earned her the ire of the
other members of the team to this end
because the body-swapping storyline had
been left unresolved prior to
Claremont's departure in an effort to
wrap up loose ends
Scott Liddell instituted a full-scale
battle between psylocke and Jean Grey
leading to the return of Psylocke other
half who was inducted onto the team
keeping the unofficial psylocke around
long enough to contract the legacy virus
which existed as a plague killing
virtually every mutant that contracted
it the unofficial Psylocke was killed
off leaving Betsy as the one true
Psylocke losing the memories of Kuantan
restoring the full might of her powers
and eliminating the confusing concept of
two characters
as a result psy locks romantic interest
in Cyclops was dropped and instead
replaced with a romantic relationship
with Warren Worthington now with this
time period saw marvel vacating all of
the existing x-men titles for six months
during the Age of Apocalypse storyline
following the events conclusion and
return of the Marvel Universe's
continuity over the next several years
leading into 2005 SCI locks time on the
team saw her going against shadow king
during the crimson dawn story arc
swapping powers of Jean Grey during
revolution as well as dying and being
resurrected during Claremont's time on
extreme x-men which existed as Marvel's
attempt to update the team for modern
readers that said if you recall my
various discussions on joke Asada's time
as editor-in-chief we had talked about
how his view of Marvel was that the
stories contained within had begun
moving away from previous light-hearted
entries in favor of darker stories some
of which alienated readers who weren't
looking for down and gritty events
instituting massive retcons and complete
upheavals during Marvel's House of M
series in 2005 which saw Scott at which
were in reality and providing all of
Earth's heroes with the lives they
wanted because of her intense telepathic
powers psylocke alongside Rachel summers
the daughter of Jean and Cyclops from
the Days of Future past were pulled into
the white-hot Room of the Phoenix where
they remained immune to the effects of
scarlet witch's influence however this
immunity was short-lived in the
following the arrival of Jaime braddock
who had been driven insane by events
within his own storylines his powers of
minor reality working were enough to
force psylocke and Rachel into the House
of M continuity where they alongside the
rest of Marvel's lineup wants an attack
against Scarlet Witch and forced her to
return reality to the way it was
now while the post house of M landscape
would see ninety-eight percent of the
mutant population losing their powers
whether it was due to psylocke being a
fan favorite or something else for
reasons I don't know Sonic's ours
remained intact and she was removed from
the x-men team and instead whirled over
into the Exile under Chris Claremont
existing as a team similar to the
all-new all-different Ultimates and that
the exhales functioned to correct
anomalies in the multiverse while the
group did consist of various characters
from other realities psyops introduction
actually came at the tail end of the
titles lifespan and that it was canceled
with issue number 100 in 2008
jumping to the launch of uncanny x-force
in 2010 as a black ops team founded by
Wolverine and operating without anyone's
knowledge writer Rick Remender brought
Psylocke on board to fight alongside
Wolverine as well as Deadpool and
Fantomex an artificial being created as
a 13th iteration of the weapons Plus
program where vendors run received
universal acclaim owing to the fair of
storytelling including the death of the
reborn apocalypse and the Dark Angel
storyline which focus on the aftermath
and Warren Worthington playing a role as
apocalypse the popularity of uncanny
x-force led into psylocke first solo
mini-series in 2010 written by
Christopher Yost centering on silo
travelling to Japan in order to bury her
former body this story saw her seeking
out Matsui OCU raba
the man who would swap her original body
with Kwan ins in the first place as she
proceeds with her mission to find and
kill Mott CEO however she discovers that
she has been set up and that Mott CEO
had baited her into pursuing him in the
hopes that she would kill him and in the
torture he endures from her fellow x-men
member Wolverine who blames Mott CEO for
poisoning a woman that he loved named mo
Rico leading into a battle between
psylocke and Wolverine due to her moral
objection to this torture that his
conclusion the story saw Wolverine
acquiescing allowing psylocke to kill
Mott CEO and end his suffering that
following the conclusion of this
miniseries between 2013 and 2015 as part
of Marvel now and all-new model now
leading in a Secret Wars psylocke
largely remained a background character
with the exception of her role and x-men
vol 4 under writer brian wood and
x-force vol 4 under letter simon
Spurrier where she was paired with storm
rogue Rachel gray Jubilee and Kitty
Pryde and x-men and cable Fantomex
marrow doctor nemesis and Eva in x-force
while these stories were well received
due to their writing and storytelling
because the events of secret Wars was on
the horizon with Hickman's run of
Avengers and New Avengers both x-men and
x-force were cancelled in April and June
of 2015
going into secret Wars proper now in
terms of the all-new all-different
marvel landscape while uncanny x-men was
relaunched as a continuation of vol 4 in
truth the new series actually came out
of writer colon buns magneto solo series
focusing on Aaron bringing together
psylocke arc angel mone st. croix
speak Fantomex the saber-tooth in an
effort to bring about xavier stream the
team was designed to have questionable
moral codes imposing their will on
mutants whether they want it or not
to this end while we're only seven
issues end the existing issues largely
focus on the continuation of x-men vol
force Dark Angel saga combined with
apocalypse wars emphasizing the idea of
Warren Worthington taking on an
apocalypse form and its inner struggle
with both the dark and light personas
again while the idea is still being
fleshed out we still don't have a solid
understanding of what direction the full
expanse of the story will take but at
the moment Psylocke appears to largely
maintain your role as a hero with
occasional dips in the moral ambiguity
and an occasional left for killing with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and let me know I'm
curious let me know how you guys felt
about Psylocke and the x-men apocalypse
movie and I will catch you guys later
peace